[موسيقى]
مرحبا شاهدتم ابرز فيديوهات الاسبوع
الماضي لكن ماذا عن اخباره لنتابعها معا
بايجاز من الغرفه اخبار الجزيره هيا بنا
لنبدا من باكستان ومحاوله اغتيال رئيس
الحكومه المقال عمران خان حيث نجا من
عمليه اطلاق نار على حافلته اثناء تجمع
انتخابيه في البنجاب واتهم رئيس الحكومه
وزير الداخليه بالتخطيط لقتله ودعم مؤيديه
للخروج والتظاهر ضد ما وصفها بالحكومه
المستورده الحكومه رفضت هذه الاتهامات
ودعت حزب انصاف لمراجعه ترتيباته الامنيه
لحمايه الاحتجاجات ليه نسال مراسلنا عبد
الرحمن مطر عن تطورات الاحداث هناك
مرحبا عبد الرحمن اجواء متوتره اذا خلفتها
هذه الحادثه هل تتجه الاوضاع نحو مزيد من
التصعيد
الوضع حقيقه مازال يتفاعل هنا في باكستان
التيما مع اسرار حزب انصاف بزعامه رئيس
الحكومه المقال من منصبه عمران خان على
اتهام رئيس الحكومه ووزير الداخليه وضابط
كبير في المخابرات في الوقوف والتخطيط
لعمليه اغتياله ورفض الحكومه لتركه
الاتهامات والان دخول الجيش حقيقه في
معترك الصراع بين الحكومه وحزب انصاف
وتاكده على ضروره ان يتم اتخاذ اجراء
قانوني وقضائي بحق عمران خان لايقافه عن
مثل فرقه التصريحات شكرا لك يا عبد الرحمن
مدير مكتبنا في باكستان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يشن غارات على غزه استهدفت
مجمعه لتصنيع مكونات الصواريخ التابع
لحركه حماس وقال ان العمليه رد على اطلاق
صواريخ بينما وصفت حماس القصفه بانهم
امتداد للحرب المفتوحه على الشعب
الفلسطيني اما على الصعيد السياسي فقد
اعلنت لجنه الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
النتائج النها والتي اظهرت حصولها معسكر
اقصى اليمين لزعامه بنيمنتنياهو على
اغلبيه واضحه مما يتيح له تشكيل الحكومه
لنسال زميلنا علاء الدين حماد عن سبب قدره
نتنياهو على العوده مجددا لاستعاده
الحكومه ايضا تابعات هذه النتائج مرحبا بك
علاء ماذا تعني هذه النتيجه
تعني عوده كل مشاريع نتنياهو التي توقفت
في المطر الفتره الماضيه عوده مشاريع
التطبيعه مع الدول العربيه عوده مشروع ضمن
الاغوار التي كان الفتره حضرتك تتوتر الى
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده في الملف
النووي وغيره وتعني عوده همم الى الحكم
الحصانه الكامله من الملاحقه القضائيه ضد
قضاء الفساد التي شكرا جزيلا علاء وتجدون
متابعينا في التعليقات المزيد عن حياه
صعوده للمره الرابعه على التوالي اذا
البنك المركزي الامريكي يرفع سعر الفائده
بمقدار 72 نقطه اساس ضمن معركته لخفض
التضخم الحاد وتجنبا للركود في اكبر
اقتصاد بالعالم الخطوه تبعتها خطوات
مماثله من بنوك مركزيه حول العالم يقال ان
رفع سعر الفائده الاداء النقديه الابرز
لدى كافه البنوك المركزيه لكبح جماح
التضخم لكنها قد لا تصيب دائما نسال في
هذا الشان زميلنا منتجه النشره الاقتصاديه
عمار مرحبا بك عمار لماذا الاستمرار في
رفع اسعار الفائده للمره الرابعه محمد كما
تعلم بان همم سعر الفائده هي واحده من
ادوات النقديه هذا البنك المركزي الامريكي
في سبيل التحكم في التدخل يمكن ان يشبه
هذه الاعداد بالحنفيه كل ما تم رفع اسعار
الفائده تقل السيول نتيجه ان الشركات
والافراد يقلون همم في الاستدامه لان كلفت
الاختيارات تصبح همم مكلف لدى البنوك هذه
العمليه ينتج عنها تراجع في طلب تراجع في
السيوله وبالتالي تتراجع الاسعار والنتيجه
نوعا التحكم في التضخم
سليمان مستويات القياسيه التي تتجاوز لها
8% وهي الاعلى خلال 40 عام شكرا يا محمد
فك هي الجديد اذا هاجم بايضا تويتر وقال
ان
له اشترى منصه تنشر الاكاذيب في ارجاء
العالم في وقت كشفت فيه وثيقه داخليه
تسريحه 50% من موظفي تويتر في ارجاء
العالم ماذا فعل شركات كبرى لتعليق
الاعلانات على المنصه ماسك برر الخطوه
منخفاض الارباح كما اعلن فرضا رسوما قدرها
ثمانيه دولارات شهريا مقابل خدمه علامه
التحقق الزرقاء على المنصات لقيه القرارات
جادلا واسعا له نقرا بعض التغريدات نبدا
باحمد الميموني الذي يقول هذا الظاهر
بيطلع فلوس استثماره على حساب المغندين
سامي عايش تقول انه امر محزن قراءه
تغريدات موظفيه تويتر الذين استيقظوا على
خبر عدم قدرتهم على الدخول الى حساباتهم
لقد تغير العالم العالم مونديال قطر كان
حاضرا في القمه العربيه التي عقدت
بالجزائر القاده العرب اعلن عاندتهم
للدوحه في احتضان كاس العالم ولده بحمالات
التشويه والتشكيك التي تطالوها وعبر عن
ثقتهم التامه في قدرتها على تنظيم نسخه
مميزه من هذه التظاهرات العالميه امير قطر
كان قد اعرب عن اسفه لتعرض بلاده لحمله
غير مسبقه من الافتراءات وازدواجيه
المعايير بسبب استضافتها للمونديال كما
ندد وزير الخارجيه بنفاق من يطالبون
بمقاطعه كاس العالم حسب وصفه اذا ازدواجيه
معايير في التعامل مع هذا الحدث برايكم ما
سبب ذلك شاركونا ارائكم في التعليقات
ونلتقي بكم من جديد في انجاز الاخر
الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]